do you think there's anything that can
be done
about the current imbalance in the
sexual marketplace no like are there
things no we're that's it no that's
that's just not
i'm sorry to be negative but this is
just how it is again we're talking about
reality as it were
and i think that
this sort of phenomenon just plays
itself out
right um we're on a path that is is not
is not a recent thing right this has
been going on since the 1960s with the
invention of the birth control pill
and it's sort of it's it's metastasized
from that and it's it's 50 60 years in
the making and so naturally assuming
that there's a solution to this problem
is incorrect it has to play its way out
and i think
there is some positive here or at least
some some silver lining here in that
if you look at
rates of crack cocaine usage in the
inner cities in the 1990s a lot of the
reason or a major reason why young
children didn't do crack okay is because
they saw the effect that it had on their
parents generation so i think that
successive generations will look at the
way the current dating marketplace is
structured and save themselves well i
don't want that sort of life and they
may just be able to learn from the the
examples set by their predecessors
i think that makes sense so do you think
there's going to be a resurgence then in
more traditional values yeah i would
think so because when when a system i
don't think people are done per se i
think that they are
under-informed or they
lack knowledge on a specific thing and
if presented with a requisite amount of
knowledge they're able to make the right
decision ultimately
and i don't think that's just at in the
individual level i think that is at the
societal level and if a lot of people
are very much aware of how the dating
marketplace is structured and the
deleterious effects of it they're more
than likely to restructure the way that
they go about engaging with
relationships with with the people
around them
i completely agree and that's why
freedom of speech is so important too
because if you just let people have
information like we're smart enough and
say on average smart enough to look at
the information and then come to
conclusions if you have
all of the information right and not
just a subset that pushes you in one
direction right yeah right
right knowledge is incredibly important
and as you pointed out it's it's it's
it's the freedom to to have this
knowledge accessible and be able to make
decisions based off of that knowledge
whether or not you make a mistake or
make the right decision is irrelevant as
long as you're able to make the decision
the decision with the information
available is all that matters
yeah i agree
okay what are your thoughts on
only fans
i think it's a fantastic business model
i really do because it it you know in
one sense it it does capitalize on
something which is quite lucrative and
that's emotional connection a lot of
young men out there are not able to get
into a relationship for a variety of
reasons maybe they play too much video
games maybe they they don't really work
on themselves but only fans takes
advantage of this particular situation
and it it allows women specifically to
make quite a bit of money but of course
there are negative negative aspects of
it right again it's it's
it
it does deal in in
you know degeneracy in in some ways
right you know one is selling not quite
selling their body but but engaging in
behavior that is not necessarily you
know conducive to building a healthy
society let's say
so
while i don't i don't necessarily blame
these women for the hustle
i i do think that it does represent a a
wound within society
that this sort of industry is very
popular although
you know prostitution is the oldest
profession as they say and while only
fans is not prostitution let's make that
clear
it is sort of a derivative
yeah do you think there's a type of
woman that can do that kind of work like
you said is not prostitution but it's
a derivative
do that kind of work and not have
negative consequences later just be like
yeah i was like it was fine it didn't
bug me and it was something i did when i
was younger maybe and like
yeah and there are people that can
handle that certainly or do you think it
leaves a bad imprint period it does i
mean i think in in one sense i don't
know i can't speak on the psychological
aspect of it the emotional aspect of it
because i don't i don't know that
literature well enough i would assume i
would assume that it does
but i will say that you know the
internet is forever and
if an employer is able to look up your
internet history and see that you've had
an only fans page
maybe they'd be less inclined to give
you a job maybe
hmm
this is true yeah
yeah that's terrifying yeah
the internet is forever that's
terrifying
how would you this is this is fun how
would you describe what being a simp is
for people who don't know what that
means ah okay that's a good question so
a simp is a
transcendent nice guy he is the type of
guy that placates to a woman that
pedestalizes her and
engages in you know undo praise and
gives gifts for the sake of receiving
emotional connection and sex so there is
no emotional connection there is no
genuine interest in a woman he's simply
doing it because
praising her and giving her gifts
because he wants something in return
so simp is
i think within modern parlance it's it's
used to describe a male that is
subservient
wow that might have been the best
definition of a simp that i've heard
thank you that was yeah i always thought
that totally makes sense too i always
thought it was kind of
a man who's
probably more agreeable
and
is is being nice out of guilt or
something but you think it's just a
direct transaction it's do things nice
to receive
sex basically yes it's it's creepier
yeah for sure i think it's machiavellian
nature and i think the term actually is
very related to the sneaky [ __ ]
syndrome so this is used to describe
yeah yeah you know fish and specific
animals in the animal kingdom
that are not able to cut it so they're
not able to reproduce with with females
of of that specific species so they'll
look for very sneaky ways to impregnate
the species so male gobi fishes as an
example uh the ones that are smaller are
not able to to reproduce to fertilize
eggs the larger male goby fish are able
to do so so the smaller ones will either
hide or disguise themselves as females
and when the males are away they'll
sneakily
fertilize the eggs
that's hilarious
that's hilarious how does that kind of
thing even evolve it's not like these
fish can think right now like i better
better decide i'm a female now just
screw over this big guy yeah you know i
think you touch on an important point
here because i think it's all instinct
and it's not only just in among animals
so goby fish but also uh human beings
and there's a natural instinct to
reproduce and you'll look for as many
strategies or try as many strategies as
you can and you'll find the one that
works best and
maybe simping is that option that a lot
of people have i wouldn't recommend it i
mean if one applies a bit of game theory
as i've done in a paper you realize that
it's it's not it's not conducive to um
being able to have a long-term
relationship you'll probably get played
wow okay
so there's a couple questions from that
um
hmm what do i want to start with that's
scary so you said i did i never i never
actually thought about that kind of
behavior of like a simp as
machiavellianist
like so you suggested that there's like
danger there ish
in a sense i i think that it is not born
out of good intentions that there's a
level of manipulation involved which i
think is the standard definition of what
it means to be machiavellian is to be
manipulative and so it's you're not
you're not engaging with a woman out of
necessarily a love for her that is that
is you know that is pure and that is not
that is not based on any sort of um
negativity it is more so that you are
engaging with her
uh in order to receive something in
return which is sex or maybe even
emotional connection so there's no
there's no genuine genuine desire for
this person
beyond beyond a base desire to have sex
this is why i don't trust agreeable men